pero
[Música]
aunque como se puede ver en la plaza se
ha erigido el árbol de navidad y se está
preparando el pesebre estos días en
muchos hogares se están preparando estos
dos símbolos de la navidad para la
alegría de niños y adultos son signos de
esperanza especialmente en este periodo
difícil tiempo difíciles
esto me duele mucho me duele mucho el
corazón pero si el precio de estas
sutilezas es que nuestras muertes ahora
son de 590 personas al día entonces esto
no es aceptable y entonces tenemos que
ajustar eso
una piñata es la que representan los 7
peca2 capitales' son los 7 picos
y la de 5 es la que representa la
estrella de belén porque aquí en acolman
lo de la piñata porque la utilizaron
para poder evangelizar a los indígenas y
aparte fue la primer piñata que se
quebró a nivel latinoamérica
[Música]
vamos a buscar el tío y cuando lo
encontramos lo ponemos debajo del árbol
lo tapamos con una manta y le damos de
comer
sola con sentirse la gente por lo menos
al ver al niño jesús con barbijo que
realmente ellos tienen que usar también
va a hervir en esta ocasión por navidad
estamos entregando ofreciendo a todos
los animales de la colección son los que
diversos enriquecimientos con el fin de
que ellos exploren se frote y muestren
comportamientos propios que ellos
mostrarían en la naturaleza
el niño coge el betis y lo pone lo pone
aquí en el centro de cuidados primero
para ver lo ponemos dentro de la máquina
que nos va a decir si sí o no tiene un
virus o no le tengo miedo al coronavirus
creo que tenemos que usar el sentido
común intento encontrar ventajas espero
que ahora hayamos aprendido a lavarnos
las manos y preocuparnos por la higiene
personal
francamente solía ser un gran problema
pero pudiera pedir un deseo y ponerlo en
el árbol diría el único deseo es que
este virus sea derrotado y que el mundo
pueda estar en paz y serenidad en el
monto para serenar de paso este limitado
[Música]
a los libaneses les gusta salir quedarse
hasta tarde y divertirse no somos
personas que se sientan y lloran sobre
las ruinas
queremos vivir salir y quedarnos fuera
me da miedo porque creo que el más
rápido volvimos a comprar un lote si no
estamos a favor no si me da miedo la
verdad y me da miedo
[Música]
curiosamente el lado positivo de este
año es que hemos vuelto a cosas mucho
más esenciales como el espíritu navideño
en familia es decir estamos menos
centrados en el exceso
[Música]